August police reports calls real harm  they do harm to every legitimate victim  who the need of support by police and  investigators as well as the citizens of  the city Chicago hosts one of the  largest pride parades in the world and  we're proud of that as a police  department and also as a city we do not  know when we ever tolerate hate in our  city whether that hate is based on an  individual sexual orientation race or  anything else so I'm offended by what's  happened and I'm also angry I love the  city of Chicago and the Chicago Police  Department warts and all but this  publicity stunt was a scar that Chicago  didn't iron and certainly didn't deserve